you're very pro-free speech
pro-capitalism
so given that it's very interesting that
you're also pro-establishment and
pro-institutions
uh so right now if you look at the world
there's a significant distrust of
Institutions uh at least in sort of
public intellectual discourse uh what is
the nature of your support for
government and institutions can you make
the case for and against them
broadly speaking
there is a synergistic effect when two
humans come together if I can speak very
broadly in terms of we'll say utility
okay my happiness with one person might
be ten the happiness of a person might
be ten but when they come together it's
like 50 between the two of them there's
like the synergistic effect when humans
work together that the sum is greater
than all the individual parts or
whatever there's like an emergent thing
that happens there there's a capacity
there's a possibility of that yeah a
possibility sure things could go really
wrong there could be a cannibalistic
drive that all eats each other for sure
but for the purpose of this there's
other failure modes but yes okay sure
yeah for the for the but well I think
broadly speaking you're are you going to
be the well actually guy okay if you
wanna okay well actually well actually
sometimes yeah
true yeah sometimes things do going but
I think broadly speaking the fact that
you're sitting here in clothing that you
didn't make and I'm sitting here on an
airplane that I don't know how to fly or
build like right there's a lot of cool
stuff that happens when people come
together and they make civilizations and
part of that civilization building is
the fact that we can specialize and it's
the fact that we can offload a bunch of
trust onto third parties that we
delegate the power to make important
decisions about our lives right I don't
know anything about how to like build
like a combustion engine but I know that
when I push the button on my car it's
going to drive around and the fumes
aren't going to kill me and I can park
it in garages and the building's not
going to collapse and the only reason
all of this works is because I've
offloaded a lot of trust under these
third-party things and I would say that
the pillars of these third-party things
that Society is built on are roughly
speaking institutions so that might be
the institution of peer review for
scientific articles it might be the
institution of uh voting for government
right or the the ability for us to vote
in that whole process it might yeah all
the FDA like all of these institutions
are things that they need to exist
because we don't have the time or the
capability to individually sort through
all of those all of these things
individually we have to rely on some
certain you to do it okay so you believe
at scale the when we're together we're
greater than the sum of our parts that's
the case for institutions absolutely
what about the inefficiencies of
bureaucracy is there some aspect when at
scale
different Dynamics coming to play than
they do when there's two people together
two people that love each other the
birds and the bees is there some aspect
that leads more to cannibalism at scale
so like corruption inefficiencies that
due to bureaucracy and so on bureaucracy
which is not I hate it when people try
to say bureaucracy is government because
bureaucracy exists a ton in private
environments as well right in businesses
and everything
um bureaucracy introduces its own set of
problems but I mean a bureaucracy is
necessary because it's coordinating all
of the underlying things in order in
order to create something that's greater
than the sum of its parts right like all
of the software developers in the world
are useless without being paired with
good designers in order to make their
products usable by a person and the
coordination of those people and the
coordination of increasingly more and
more things necessitates some level of
bureaucracy I think we always say
bureaucracy when it's like a bad it's
like a slur almost like you're a
bureaucrat you're bureaucratic the
bureaucracy is slowing everything down
it's like sure the bureaucracy slows
things down but bureaucracy also gives
us things like you know safe medicine
and safe water to drink for most of the
US or safe buildings to live in or safe
cars to drive so so the managers and
institution versus like the software
developers and the designers the
managers is the bureaucracy the the
reason bureaucracy is used as a slur is
that something about human nature
leads to bureaucracy often growing
growing indefinitely becoming less and
less efficient without a I mean this is
what capitalism can come in that
capitalism puts a pressure on the
bureaucracy not to grow too much because
you want the bureaucracy to be useful
but not large yeah and to be a certain
size yeah of course to be the minimum
size to get the job done and so
capitalism provides that mechanism
government
does not always and so that's the
criticism of government of Institutions
where it can grow without a significant
mechanism that says there's a cost to
bureaucracy that's not being accounted
for here we're just paying for the
increasing size of government without
the benefit yeah government is a special
institution because it doesn't have to
show itself to be financially viable and
we kind of live in a capitalist economy
where that's generally the case so
government gets its powers from votes
from the people which introduces a whole
new set of possible positives and
possible negatives right having
something for instance that gives food
or shelter to homeless people maybe you
don't want that to have to run at a
profit but giving you know an
organization that can self-justify its
budgets perpetually and definitely
growing maybe that's not the best thing
yeah we always have to figure out how to
do the constraints there but what about
the the corrupting nature of power
that comes with institutions as well
absolutely so then you better pick your
your style of institution very carefully
I think that the Democratic institution
we have in the United States today I
think works very well but I mean there
are other styles of government that have
been tried in the past that I think lend
themselves more to corruption not to say
that by the way there's not corruption
in the United States of course there's
going to be varying levels of corruption
at like all
um at all levels but you're right you
run into this interesting problem where
authoritarian regimes can act with
ruthless precision and swiftness because
they don't have to ask any questions
they just do do do do and that's it
um but the problem is is it's an
authoritarian regime they're prone to
missteps they're slow to respond to
changing or evolving needs there's an
interesting study that was put out a
while ago that showed that like every
single famine that happened around the
world almost all like 98 of them happen
under authoritarian regimes where like
freedom of speech is very limited it's
very rare for a famine to happen under
uh democracy because press and
everything makes the government more
responsive to the needs of the people
power can corrupt their levels of
corruption but you have to have like a
system of checks and balances on on all
of those different levels to make sure
it doesn't run off the rails I guess and
do a sick loop-de-loop and you know half
the population gets
nice call back there's a lot of people
that list that will listen to you say
that the Democracy in the United States
is working pretty damn well and and they
will spit out the drink if they're
drinking a drink
and uh be very upset uh can you make the
case that they're right and you're wrong
can I make the case he's still man
they're right yeah well the steel man
for them is that people have a lot of
problems on the day-to-day and when they
look and they see what government is
doing
um they might see potholes outside their
house homeless people all over their
downtown and the United States just
approved another x billion amount of
dollars for Ukraine or they might be
living in a city where half the
factories are shut down a lot of their
people out of work but the president is
on the TV talking about how to find jobs
for immigrants coming in from Mexico and
for these people they have problems that
exist in their lives there some of them
are paying taxes to alleviate these
problems and then we listen to the when
they listen to the government talk it
feels like the government is not
responding to the needs that they have
and then that's one problem then on top
of that you've got all of these people
working in alternative media they can
show you well look at this politician
wasting this much money or look at him
double speaking here or there look at
Hillary Clinton saying she's got a
private position in a public position
look at how all of these politicians
have family members that are getting
rich because of their relationships with
people in Congress look at the revolve
door between capitalist companies and
the government how can you look at all
of that take into account that the
government's not responding to your
needs and then really feel like it's a
government by the people and for the
people yeah this was very good good
Steel Man and good question how can you
how can you how can you tell that
they're not just politicians that care
more about continuously winning the
elections versus being uh running
government effectively they should care
about winning the elections that's the
first misconception a lot of people say
if this guy only cares about getting
voted in this guy like he doesn't even
believe about in a in fracking or
abortion he just changed his opinion to
get voted in anytime somebody says that
you should say that's really good you
want them to change their opinion so
they get put it in that's the whole
point of a democracy you don't want them
to be remain obstinate you don't want
them to say I'm not changing my opinion
no matter what the people want you want
them to evolve and adopt new opinions
based on what the population their
constituents are voting for yeah but the
cynical take is that they're the cert on
the surface they're changing their
opinion but that there's a boys club
where boys means the elite that under in
the smoke filled rooms
in secret they're actually have their
own agenda and they're following that
agenda and they're just saying anything
publicly to placate the public based on
whatever the the the new trends are so
this is yeah I understand somebody asked
me this question and it flipped I I 180
completely um I was a Bernie Sanders
supporter in 2016 and my my single issue
voting thing was lobbying I thought that
lobbying the government was corrupt they
weren't responding to people it was
completely destroyed my faith in
government everything and I had one
question posed To Me by a conservative
that used to come home ice cream and
chat with me and he said
um and then he asked me can you think of
any
any popular opinion that the American
public has that the government is
unresponsive to is there some big piece
of legislation or policy or whatever
that people want that the government
isn't doing
they asked me that I couldn't think of a
single good answer I'm like oh geez this
is a good answer there's drugs there's
not drugs legalization of drugs yeah go
for it you're doing The Joe Rogan thing
you're pushing back because I brought up
weed go ahead
I'm sorry I have become meme
uh no uh because people bring up okay
okay there's no issues there's no issues
that the government is not representing
of the public so here's the issue so
somebody will bring up like well what
about the legalization of drugs okay the
first issue people have is one they look
at National polling yeah very few things
are decided on a national level so
that's the first huge mistake arguably a
lot of BLM made mistakes in this um
Arena where they're saying like why
isn't the government doing anything
about policing federal government can't
do anything about policing that's going
to be your sometimes any of your state
government some of your local city
government the people that like elect
like your chief of police your Police
Commissioner that's coming from your
mayor right
um so you've got people looking one at
the wrong parts of the government even
figure out the solution to the problem
two oftentimes for polling the questions
are vague enough that you can pull very
high when you get into the Weeds on
things no pun intended you start to
realize like oh shoot this is more
complicated I thought I don't know the
numbers in particular for legalization
of America wanna but this is what I'm
gonna guess is the case if you pull and
you say should we legalize marijuana
that number might pull at like 65 70
percent
but that's including people that are in
favor of medical marijuana if you were
to pull like should we legalize should
we decriminalize recreational use of
marijuana that never might drop to like
52 and then if you pull like should we
completely legalize not just economics
completely legalize recreationalism I
dropped like 40 there's like all these
different ways you can pull around
issues where people like oh no we
broadly agree on this topic when you
really figure out well do you do we
really agree or is it just like broad
consensus or anything that's never going
to show up like in a piece of
legislation a really good example one
example I do know is socialized
Healthcare I think if you pull there was
a time a few years ago where if you pull
America do you think every American
citizen should have access to uh like
free health care I think that answer
that pulled like 74 yes but when you
asked should the government be the Sole
Provider of Health Care it dropped to
like 26 dropped 50 points and you could
see it was both asking questions about
single-payer but the way that it was
asked was so different that even if you
all it looks like there's consensus
there's not nearly as much consensus as
people think around certain ideas
you're right you're right you're right
that polls the way you ask the polls
really matters but when you ask should
the government be in charge of a thing
that also biases the answer right that
like because there's such a Negative
experience with government creating
a.gov site that runs the thing but
sometimes sometimes I think if you dig
in if you have a one-hour conversation
with each individual citizen sure I
think you will understand that yes there
is support for socialized medicine like
it's not the argument has to be made
though yeah well what do you mean like
if you just ask a conservative like what
about single-payer they're gonna tell
you no you might be able to build up to
an argument for it but you're gonna have
to make the case for it no but I thought
we're talking about
the feeling deep inside your mind and
heart does the government represent that
oh so it's not like some shallow surface
layer public opinion does the government
effectively represent what the people
want
not a shallow survey but a deeply what
they want I'm not actually that familiar
with the debates over health care but
let's maybe look at an easier one maybe
you'll say it's harder war war is a
really good example where the government
was very responsive I think to the
people you think so so Iraq Afghanistan
the government didn't manipulate
public opinion there's an argument to be
made that they did in terms of like wmd
and everything but after 9 11 were you
in the United States after 9 11 after 9
11. I legit seemed accusatory like what
were you and then
just checking okay all right cool I have
evidence and uh oh sure Witnesses
I'm very defensive right now it's very
strange look into it Alex yeah I think
after 9 11 we could have gone to Country
we could have gone to war with any
country in the world we would have we
were ready because all of America was
like oh my God and they pointed to Iraq
and you know the reasons for the wmds
was kind of dumb but I don't think we
even needed wmds to go to Iraq we could
have just said you know Saddam Hussein
was giving Medical Aid to Taliban
Al-Qaeda Iraq let's go and we would have
gone for it but um post Iraq Iraq was
for a while popular and then became
obviously deeply unpopular Iraq and
Afghanistan and I think you could see
that influence other foreign policy that
the United States had for instance we
opted more towards like drone Warfare
than troops on the ground for places
like Yemen we opted more towards like
kind of like sending money and help
instead of boots on the ground for
places like Syria and I think that a lot
of that was kind of in response to how
unpopular the Iraq stuff had became and
when you looked at a lot of Elections
afterwards even for Obama like one of
the defining characteristics of a lot of
campaigns were like I'm going to close
Guantanamo Bay I'm going to get us out
of Foreign Wars even up to Trump I'm
going into I'm you know I'm not going to
stop doing all this weird stuff in the
Middle East but they didn't still
withdraw from a guest then they didn't
withdraw but they definitely like
tapered off and weren't like as
aggressively pushing those types of
conflicts because they knew it was
unpopular but I think if you also
consider perfect information or or good
information if you ask a lot of people
are you okay spending this amount of
money money
for this purpose so military conflict in
Iraq and Afghanistan I think almost from
the very beginning they would say no
after 9 11 I feel like maybe like a few
days after 9 11 like I remember what was
it
well there's there's some memes and so
on yes but the nature of the public
support for the war
was there public support in 2003 which
is when The Invasion happened
I feel like initially there was a lot I
remember seeing it on but then I also
lived in a republican household and I
was not very like media Savvy at that or
something I don't know if the nature of
that public support had to do with wmds
or with 911 because the weird came about
wmds but I wonder what what is the name
if you were to pull people and let's say
hypothetically there was above 50
support for the war what would be the
nature of that support and
due to what degrees the government
actually representing the will of the
people versus
some complex mechanism like the
military-industrial complex is
manipulating The Narrative that's
controlling public opinion and then
there's the media that uh gets a lot of
attention by being divided and how
they're shaping The Narrative through
the mechanism of division so what
there's a lot of complicated things yes
it's not just like the people and then
the government and that's yeah for sure
I agree that there are going to be
different elements at play and how much
of those elements that lead us astray
can be attributed to the largeness of
the different systems so and the
different institutions like the the
media institutions and government
the institutions that have a monopoly on
violence let's put it this way which is
what one way to define government sure
it's complicated
um there's definitely different
institutions at play I but I think that
like all I would say is like in
reference to my original point when
there becomes like broad consensus
around a thing I think the government
will usually follow it's not going to
fight it's going to follow more often
than not
um but I think that a lot of times I
think Americans think that there's more
consensus around certain issues and
there actually are um so like a really
good example we're on that warp Point
too
um what caused like the lowest dip in
Biden's approval rating
I'm pretty sure it was right after we
pulled out of Afghanistan which I think
if I would have asked people like a year
before like let's assume that we could
pull out of Afghanistan
um the government's probably going to
collapse after we leave because they
just don't have the will to fight they
don't have the support they don't
whatever that's just not going to work
but like no Americans are going to die
there might be a couple other people but
like no America's gonna die we're gonna
finish would you support that I think
broadly speaking I think I think like
more than 60 or 70 of Americans are like
yeah that would be fine but then when it
actually plays it on TV when we see the
people hang on to the planes when we see
like helicopter Embassy some of the
quotes from politicians well now it's
like oh my God this was horrible and it
was so botched and it was so like it
could have gone so much better well
could it have gone better like maybe
maybe not but I mean it seems like you
can have consensus around a certain
opinion but the way that things play out
and the way that people actually feel
it's actually way way way more
complicated and there's not usually this
broad consensus opinion when all right
yeah go ahead I'd like to believe that I
mean just to leave my cards out on the
table
I have uh faith
in the power of Effective Government
I just
have
um a lot of concern about what happens
as institutions grow in size for sure
and I just have a lot of worry about the
natural corrupting influence on the
individuals and on the system as a whole
like the the boys club nature of it I
don't know there must be a better term
but basically they
they agreed to the game and they play
the game and there's a generational
aspect momentum to the game and they
more and more stop being responsive to
the people that they represent I just
feel like there is that mechanism and I
think the nice thing democracy elections
are resistance to that natural human
mechanism
um also the balances of power is a
resistance to that mechanism in some
ways the media that reveals the [ __ ]
of politicians is also a resistance to
that mechanism it's it's hard to be full
of [ __ ] as a politician because people
try to catch you on it so there's a
honesty method there that keeps you
honest it's to some degree but it still
feels like
it still feels like politicians are
going to politician
yeah they definitely play their games
that is true but there's probably always
going to be that meta narrative over
like governance that just develops as
like you have to form relationships and
play games to play get legislation
passed everything the only the only
reason why I don't like it when people
attack institutions is because one
institutions are incredibly important
arguably Paramount no they are to
keeping Society Running and two I think
sometimes when we shift the blame onto
institutions too much I think that we
lose sight of what the real problems are
so for instance in the United States
today people might be very critical of
the government not getting much done but
then everybody turns their eyes to the
government for being ineffective but
what I would argue is I would say the
government is actually incredibly
effective and it's showcasing the will
of the American people really well right
now which is we are historically more
divided than we have ever been and if I
were to just look at the people and I
would say we have a historic divide that
is getting like rapidly blown apart by
things like the internet and the media
right if that exists well what would I
expect that government to look like I
wouldn't expect the government to be
governing very effective I would expect
that government to show that legitimate
divide in people do you think that
divide we have a perception of a large
divide between left and right do you
think that's a real divide that's in
this country narrow the language what do
you mean by real divide
do you think there is that divide in
ideology that there's a large number of
people that believe a certain set of
policies and the different set of
policies I think that's the perception
of the on on Twitter no I think there is
a large divide in terms of belief I
don't think that's very much divided
between any people in terms of like what
they like on the most fundamental levels
want in terms like human beings but in
terms of like Democrat versus Republican
right now I think there is a huge divide
in terms of the direction they want to
see the country go and what they believe
really and what they even believe is
reality right unfortunately that's where
we've gotten to